what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent playing the e by love
america
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five's got
three products buy and sell crypto on
crypto exchange
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an interest
bearing account
i like that product they'd be paying me
and you can deposit crypto and earn
up to oh no actually you could deposit
crypto and get paid a us dollar loan to
get your crypto collateral
go get a block five account block five
dot com slash pomp blackfly.com
pomp block fi.com pop
what's up nothing my hair's still wet
but i'm good oh it's cool let's go let's
go
let's go let's get it cracking so you're
not gonna like this story but
bitcoin reached an all-time high of 28
000 on sunday
based on the charts that run might be
put on pause come
2021 according to mark newton founder
and president of newton advisors
he said it's still quite bullish on an
intermediate term basis
given that it just broke out to new
all-time highs i think we have a ways to
go
near-term my cycle composite shows us
peaking out in early january
tell jimmy neutron looking mother didn't
do it didn't curse kids show
tell jimmy neutron looking dude over
here that nobody cares
nobody cares because his name is newton
it's just jimmy neutron you gotta look
like jimmy neutron if your name is
newton
like literally you're like the little
squid in high school that kids just put
your head in the toilet and gave you a
swirly you don't know what you're
talking about
little chart technicians guess what
bitcoin doesn't
care it doesn't care what your charts
say bitcoin
ain't slowing down you know why because
bitcoiners aren't selling the
institutions are coming in
and the only way to accommodate everyone
is the us dollar price
has to go up and she just pulled up a
picture and he looks like jimmy neutron
if i can pull up the photo i would show
you he looks just like jimmy neutron
like i said he would nobody cares what
you think hey
be nice by the way i remember i bet you
me and new
newton neutron jimmy neutron guy we'd be
friends we probably would be guys that's
awesome
but don't be saying that bitcoin is
going to peter out just you know
just a reminder to be kind to your
friends jimmy neutrons
by the way we became an aunt and uncle
today because our friends had a baby
that's so exciting so uh we are an aunt
and uncle
our friend had a baby well yeah but like
anybody that's related to us
yeah it's so exciting okay grab that
baby be looking at me they'll be like
what's up
i'm like what hasn't seen you yet nah we
looked at each other through the phone
the baby was like oh look another alien
i was like what's up alien
uk based chip maker graphcore announced
tuesday that it had raised 222 million
dollar of investment
as it looks to take on u.s rivals nvidia
and intel wow 222 million and it's
thinking about
going public that's nothing it's nothing
in the ai game
it's nothing oh alert alert alert alert
breaking news breaking news breaking
news
before i forget kids if you're under the
age of 15
today is national mcdonald's day it
means that your parents
have to bring you to mcdonald's you can
get chicken nuggets you can get
mcchicken sandwiches
you can get a big mac i think no a
whopper whatever the hell they got at
mcdonald's
or you can ask does your ice cream
machine work and you can get a mcflurry
but if your parents don't bring you to
mcdonald's today it means they don't
love you
so make sure that you ask them
i have to go to mcdonald's today just
saying national mcdonald's day go ahead
i am so sorry it's national mcdonald's
all right i'm going to mcdonald's i'm
going to get fries and make chicken
sandwich
big mcflurry you're screaming okay go a
federal
judge for the second time denied bail to
gelane
maxwell the wealthy socialite accused of
grooming underage girls to be sexually
abused by money manager jeffrey epstein
she keeps trying to get bail and they
just are saying goodbye
this is the second bail rejection
innocent until proven guilty but
i'm not mad about it that she has been
denied bail
i saw a documentary that documentary
didn't make them seem like good people
oh he didn't
i mean no i mean it was a great
documentary but he did not
he was like are you serious yeah
you can do a lot of bad things in the
world and i'm just like whatever
you mess with little kids nah
yeah leave the kids alone you tell them
yeah you wanna mess with people come
mess with me see what happens you come
mess with me
picking on these little 13 year old
girls all right
they're scumbags i know okay more than
190
000 ceiling fans have been recalled
because the fans blades can detach
while in use could you imagine
king of fans of fort lottery of course
it's in florida a fort lauderdale
florida-based company that makes the
54-inch
mara ceiling fans announce the recall
after receiving 47 reports of blades
detaching
what would you do so two of those
reports indicated a detached fan plane
hit
someone my favorite part is that it's
property damage my favorite is that it's
called king of fans
maybe it should be called king of
missiles like imagine just turning the
fan on all stuff
like trying to work like you just got
like blades coming like nah
i'm good all right today today's a fun
lunch money we don't have that much news
hey
what's the next one nostradamus oh they
wrote an article about me oh my god
nostradamus who lived in the 1500s
uh famously professed
calamitous events through his les
profites a collection of poetic
quad traits the renaissance era seer
alluded to such events as the french
revolution the development of the atomic
bomb in the september 11th
terrorist attack attacks he's been
weirdly accurate
now close readers of his work say he
foresee
foresaw a 2021 even more destructive
than 2020. he's talking about asteroids
world ending asteroids zombies and fat
famine
we better stock up on some beans i think
that he uh missed by a year that sounds
like 2020
was basically like there was asteroids
there was ufos
uh at one point there was killer bees or
murder hornets
he appeared to allude to the coronavirus
pandemic of 2020 but writes that the
following year will be even
more destructive perhaps bringing famine
to the world oh no
y'all trying to tell me that nostradamus
came up with this in the 1500s there's
going to be coronavirus
yeah see after a great trouble for
humanity a greater one is prepared
hebrew
the great mover renews the ages rain
blood milk famine steel and plague
is the heavens fire scene a long spark
running oh my god no i'm scared guys
i got 20 troops this is all this is like
somebody's sitting there being like
what's going on 2020 and they like
quickly write it down and say oh look
what that's
thomas said okay a world-ending asteroid
i feel like it could happen you know
what this is this is like the crystals
for all the men out there have you guys
heard about this crystal stuff i
recently learned about crystals
wild voodoo world nobody that we know
uses crystals but he's like obsessed
with the idea of
crystals as like energy it's weird
who do you know that uses crystals i'm
not going to say the name but
i don't know we went to dinner with
somebody oh yeah
okay somebody somebody we know is into
the crystal they're not a
close friend speak for yourself i'm all
about the energy though
i can walk in a build i can walk in a
room be like bad energy here yeah well
every room you walk in no no because you
walked in
go ahead stop playing with my candle
okay ask lunch money time stop showing
them my stuff it's not show and tell
time
come on ask lunch money time oh my god
oh the little pumpkin
that's a real one come on okay from
michael mcgregor
pomp long term i know what you think but
short term three to six months is
bitcoin to buy at 27 okay my last
purchase was 17k i want more but i feel
like it's fomo at this point that's how
i feel michael i'm not answering any buy
or sell
questions on bitcoin anymore after this
one this is it i'm sticking my
flag in the ground or my foot down i'm
drawing a line in the sand whatever
you can answer whatever question i have
probably i'll probably answer one
tomorrow
uh just dollar cost average i knew you
would say that yeah just dollar cost
average i don't know where the price is
going in the short term i have no clue
it can go up it can go down it might
bitcoin's so wild it might go backwards
i don't even know how that's possible
but it might go backwards who knows you
mean like
no i'm literally just whatever my point
is who knows where it's going just keep
dollar cost averaging
and just don't look at the price
just keep accumulating you'll be fine
over a long period of time bitcoin's
going to continue to go up because of
the market structure
so that's not financial advice it's just
common sense
it's literally just dollar cost average
you should dollar cost average in the s
p 500 you should dollar cost average
into any position
just keep dollar cost averaging keep
accumulating bitcoin and chill out go
live a good life go go on the beach go
walk around
the destroyed new york city streets that
the local politicians decided they were
gonna kill all the businesses do
whatever you want to do but just chill
out and just dollar cost average all
right next
okay uh fsck
google asks hello pompiano family i have
the same question for both pimp
and anthony hoddle pompliano who is the
most influential person in your life
excluding family members
so i don't know if this counts as family
but if i'm honest
it's him very influential because he
kind of changed the way i think
i used to have poor mental models uh
didn't really you know wasn't very
confident in my approach in life
and when you have somebody who believes
in you more than you believe in yourself
and wants to see you succeed it's very
very
life-changing i have another one but
just you go my most uh what is this
question most influential person if you
don't say me i'm gonna be so mad
i'm not gonna say uh was either alan
iverson or jay-z
jay-z i'm a business man like
what just a poet straight up a poet or
alan iverson literally out here a little
five foot two
just dunking on people crossing them up
stepping over them in the corner
y'all know if you know if you know you
know but yeah when i was a kid i was
like man that dude is just got the heart
of a lion
he don't care at all he'll be out here
he'll tell you he's going to cross you
up that he crosses you up and then he
tells you he just crossed you
i'm not the most influential person in
my life now you are but your family see
i listened to the rules
he said no uh family all right anything
else
that was an expert that was an expert
weasel move
somebody called me a weasel on the
internet the other day and spelled it
wrong sided correct them whatever
see you guys wait wait wait uh we we
won't be here
tomorrow or thursday or we ain't talking
to y'all for a week no
no it's until monday yeah next monday
i'll miss you guys if you want to reach
me i'm on twitter
who wants to read though ain't nobody
want to talk to you yes they do
you trust me yes when you start talking
to or she gonna be real
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends